okay well good afternoon and thank you
for continuing to follow the Artemis
program and the Artemis One mission we
are on flight day 20 of our planned 26
day Mission and we continue to proceed
along the planned Mission profile
as Sandra indicated earlier we did
successfully complete the return powered
flyby and are now committed to an earth
return trajectory on
um on the 11th
is we've talked in the past we've had a
a number of commitments to each and
every one of you and one of those
involved what we call sharing remarkable
images and if we could queue up a series
of images here we've got a a brief
collection and this was taken on flight
day six is
um is the Orion spacecraft approached
the moon and the um and the Earth is way
off in the distance you can see eight
million people off in the distance in a
human-capable spacecraft about the
circle the moon in the foreground and
this is this is one of those remarkable
moments and remarkable images that we
show we got to share on November the
21st
a little farther along in the mission on
on flight day 13. we got to witness is
Orion
flew about the distant retrograde orbit
which is the farthest point that a human
capable spacecraft has ever flown we got
to see the Earth Transit behind the moon
extending Beyond The Pale of human space
flight what a human capable spacecraft
has done
and then later today or earlier today we
got to see a a flyby of the Moon as part
of the return powered flyby and and
witness
the the Earth rise
for the first time in the Artemis
generation and and here you see the
Orion spacecraft
um near near the point of closest
approach and then this is the earthrise
that that we witnessed orions in the
foreground the Earth isn't in the in the
distant
um background and the Moon is in the
middle there and you see the Crescent
Earth
um you know these are just a few of the
remarkable images that that we've been
able to share throughout the course
submission when we are done with this
Mission we will have traveled over 1.4
million miles in the course of the 26
day Mission and we are on track to do
that
um we still have a few primary
objectives ahead the mission is going
very well we've accomplished a number of
bonus objectives above and beyond what
we had planned pre-flight but we still
also have some risks ahead of us we
still have yet to accomplish the second
half of our Priority One objective which
is to demonstrate the spacecraft at
lunar re-entry conditions and as well as
our priority three objective which is to
retrieve the spacecraft post Splashdown
so with that I'll pass it back to you
Sandra thank you Mike next up we'll hear
from flight director Judd freeling who
was the flight director on Console
during today's return powered flyby burn
thanks Andrew let's see if we can throw
up the uh the video that Mike showed
previously about the pre uh our RPF
video I'll talk a little bit about that
as we were coming into RPF today
uh so this is a great shot uh coming
coming in uh before we we did RPF
maneuver you can see kind of there on
the lower Mill there uh we think that's
the Copernicus crater there uh that's
that's pretty near the Apollo 12 and 14
sites and we're just stunning video that
we what we captured as we were about to
to go into Los uh for our RPF burn so
RPF was the largest burn that we've done
to date it was a little over
962 foot per second burn lasted three
minutes and 27 seconds that was on the
back side of the moon we had a loss of
signal during that time period but then
as as we came back AOS uh at that time
and Mike showed that one that video as
well we saw a really outstanding shot of
the the Crescent Earth and and it was
just just stunning